how do you curse so much yeah of course
not dick face why do you feel to need
this for the loss no because it already
would curse the uses okay how do you
know that Gary swearing some of them you
get away with things so many time
[Music]
yes what time is is justice buying it
and making it essentially popular or
acceptable and at what point does it
just come really over
I think intent I think one of the
reasons I've been able to curse maybe
more than others is because I think
humans are actually unbelievably good at
having intuition around intent and I
think for a lot of people they're like
if I had to bet my life on it that's
just the Jersey boy being Jersey boy I
was inspired by Richard Pryor and Chris
Rock and Eddie Murphy and their styles
have translated to my keynote styles I
feel like I do a little bit of a
stand-up timing process and I think that
because I'm not forcing it and because
it's my Naturals own little Jersey boy
action people respect authenticity I'm
not cursing for the sake of cursing this
is how I'm comfortable in communicating
like when I think about do I care about
my employees it feels more like in my
brain and my heart and my soul do I give
a [ __ ] about my employees more than do I
care about my employees that's how my
that's for my brain and heart to my
mouth I am willing to deal with the
ramifications of me being my full self
it's not about who cares what other
people think it's if you feel good about
your intent and don't think you're
trying to do something wrong you have to
let the chips fall where they fall and
so for me that's what it is it's it's
I'm not upset or disappointed or
confused why somebody doesn't like the
bravado or the cursing I just I just
have made a choice that I don't I'm not
trying to do anything wrong it's how I
communicate and and you just have to
move forward as long as it is actually
your truth you will always over index
and people told me to not curse on state
you know my agents who look like stop
cursing on stage they were like we've
got five hundred thousand in advance
five speeches when I was making thirty
thousand a speech so this is a big jump
a hundred thousand speech but you can't
curse and like this and it needs to be
like the beginning of you not cursing
and I was like [ __ ] you
I don't feel like I need the swear to
make a point I would argue that at times
I use my cursing as a filter to filter
out the people that are not capable of
seeing the bigger picture versus being
so blocked oh my god I heard the word I
can't hear anything else everything else
must be bad there's no good advice as a
bad person that is ludicrous it goes
into the same context as the way you
dress or a million other variables of
ways people that will judge you because
at the end of the day the way you
deliver is a is all that people really
care about and the way you make them
feel I'm not cursing to disrespect
someone and I have empathy and respect
why a lot of people may not like me or
consume me there are plenty people that
don't watch this video because they saw
a keynote where I cursed and they were
offended I'm very much in this I have
respect if you're 62 year old Charlie
and you grew up a certain way where the
f we're [ __ ] is disrespectful who might
the judge I don't care that's 2018 I
don't care that it's cool now like
whatever like that's your world and I
respect that and I'll jump in and say
hey brother I I just I see the comment
like you know I get it and like if you
were I'll say what I just said if you
were brought up in a certain way I can
understand that but like if you can we
agree that if we get past that do you
see where I'm going with this or I'm
sorry I bothered you or thinks that
nature I wouldn't I would highly
recommend engage more you should instead
of saying [ __ ] you I'll show you you
need to say I hear you respect but
here's why or how or what surely I would
have a bigger audience if I didn't curse
that is absolutely true and business
respect sure I may lose out on a deal
because they were offended but then the
net net net net score I win so many more
by being me and just being me versus
creating a half version of me for the
one conservative person and leaving the
hundreds of magic business opportunities
that are predicated on winners making
decisions you know how I've lost
business I cursed in a board meeting and
somebody was very conservative and said
let's not give business to that [ __ ]
right so so like but that's okay because
I will net
net and I will tell you that it's really
the one thing I can't do is not be
myself it's been the thing that has
absolutely separated me from the pact
and so I think the truth which is very
exciting answer to this question the
truth is undefeated the amount of people
that judge me and think I'm a bad person
because I curse would be staggering to
you you just have the capability of
seeing through that and seeing the truth
and the humanity like if I spoke with a
little less energy a little less Roboto
a little less Jersey and a lot less
cursing I would be seven times bigger
it's not about boring just it wouldn't
be me it just wouldn't it's not even
exciting you can be better like I watch
a lot of stand-up comedy you couldn't
like there's great people who don't it's
just not my truth you know to be frank
I'm not pumped I'm vulgar I think no
priding first thing I don't think it's
cool I really don't I really don't I
just meet and I don't know how to be
anything but me you want a real life
lesson figure that out [ __ ] gets good
[Applause]
I'm sorry
you